for more than 16 years glen carrot has
been providing fire and safety
management in the heart of Canada's oil
industry with three shops and dozens of
vehicles the business owner would
normally have 40 to 50 employees working
at oil and gas sites around Western
Canada but these days he's down to just
five or six workers while hundreds of
thousands of dollars of leased equipment
sits idle it's disheartening to have
people sitting at home they're phoning
me on a regular basis to find out if
we're going back to work and the bills
keep piling up and you know if we don't
have all this equipment out working it's
it's cost a lot of money every day every
day it's it's Canada's oil industry has
been reeling since late 2014 when crude
prices halfed from around $100 a barrel
to less than 50 that drop led to
bankruptcies and the loss of hundreds of
thousands of jobs in oil and gas a vital
sector in Canada's economy now with more
than three billion people locked down in
their homes because of the coronavirus
the demand for oil has evaporated prices
for Western Canadian select Alberta's
benchmark heavy oil have plummeted to
less than five dollars a barrel over the
past few weeks if prices don't rise
substantially the impact on oil workers
here could be devastating OPEX record
cut and oil output has failed to prop up
the price of crude and most Canadian
producers are now well below their
break-even point we have called it a
perfect storm and in many cases you know
the folks that I work with who have been
through many different cycles in this
industry quite frankly have never seen
anything quite like this and I don't
think anyone will quite possibly ever
see anything like this again Chad Miller
was laid off a few weeks ago and with
just 30 out of 515 oil rigs in operation
across the country he knows he's not
alone Miller hopes his Facebook group
oilfield dad's will help provide support
for those worried about how they'll pay
the rent or put food on the table it's
nothing worse than hearing about
somebody's family member you know I'm
turning to drugs or alcohol or even
suicide and it's
it touches all of us because it's dear
to our hearts that you know could be any
one of us last week the Canadian
government announced the 1.7 billion
dollar aid package to try to save
thousands of energy sector jobs but with
oil storage facilities already close to
capacity and demand at historic lows the
worst may be yet to come
David Mercer al Jazeera in central
Alberta Canada